all right let's talk about hypertension
and
the first thing we have to do
is understand the two main categories or
types of hypertension that are out there
so
there are two
types
primary
and this is actually also called
essential hypertension you might hear
that word essential
and secondary and i'll write that as a
two
and so the the way that this is divided
up is that primary hypertension
is
caused
by something indirect
okay so what does that mean exactly
so i'll give you some examples of what
the indirect cause could be it could be
something like smoking
or it could be that someone has obesity
or is obese
or it could be that they have
hyperlipidemia meaning they have lots of
fats
floating around in the blood
or let's say they have diabetes that
would be another
cause or indirect cause of hypertension
and these are all risk factors right
that's another way of thinking about
these things these are general risk
factors for having hypertension
and
the other category would be something
direct
and once i write this down you'll start
seeing the difference this would be
something like kidney disease
so let's say that i have a problem with
my kidneys
and they for some reason these are my
kidneys they are holding on to far too
much fluid than they should and that's
uh because they're diseased and so
they're holding onto too much fluid and
they're causing my volume of blood to go
up they're causing the volume to go up
and the stroke volume is going up as
well and if the stroke volume goes up
you know
that you know stroke volume is going to
cause
a higher blood pressure because they're
directly related to each other very
direct that would be one example another
example could be let's say i have what's
called an aortic
coartation
so this
is a very specific problem this would be
if i have my let's say the heart is here
and i have the aorta coming off here
uh normally it should be nice and open
the way i've drawn it but if you have a
coartation
then you might have a pinching in of the
vessel so it would be it would start
looking like this it would look
like that like a pinch
and if you have a pinching in right
there
then you have increased resistance
they have increased resistance and if
you have increased resistance you know
again resistance is going to relate back
to pressure so if you have more
resistance you have higher pressure so
these are direct causes
of hypertension
which is slightly different than the
indirect causes i wrote about the
smoking obesity because there's no clear
direct mechanism in any of those things
they're just more general risk factors
so this is how we kind of divvy up the
two groups and we say okay if you have
one or the other then you're in the
primary or secondary group
so
let's figure out of the two which
is more prevalent prevalent
and this basically means which
is going to affect more people at any
point in time
so if i was to
pull all people with hypertension ask
them hey what group are you in primary
or secondary
most people would say
primary
because most of these people are going
to be smokers or obese or diabetics or
people that
have hyperlipidemia some of these risk
factors that we just laid out in fact
over 90 percent
of the people have primary
hypertension
and only a few people i would say less
than 10 percent
are going to say nope i'm actually in
the secondary group i have a very
specific reason for having hypertension
so this is actually a very easy way of
figuring out if people are
having hypertension from an indirect
cause or direct cause
all right so now let's assume that
you follow one person over time
one individual and
that person
used to have normal blood pressure let's
say this is blood pressure over here and
i'm going to write it out as mean
arterial pressure m-a-p
mean arterial pressure
and we want to maintain a mean arterial
pressure a map
you know of a certain number so this
would be like a normal blood pressure
range right something below this dashed
line
so this is normal
but of course you know many people have
something higher than normal they
over time might develop
higher blood pressure so maybe they
start out here and here you know in the
normal range and then they start having
high blood pressure
and it kind of goes up and down and up
and then down and
it stops there
so
in this person i'm going to connect the
dots
they
if you ask them would not have any
symptoms for most of the time they would
actually say you know i
feel fine i don't have any symptoms at
all in fact
up until this point in time they would
say they have no symptoms
no symptoms
and the vast majority of people are
actually in this group so most people
with hypertension if you ask them if
they have symptoms from it they would
say no they don't have any symptoms
but at some point they can develop
symptoms not everybody but you can
develop symptoms and when you do it's
usually quite significant so you might
have problems with your heart
maybe your heart is having to work
harder than it ever had to and you're
having some heart failure
or you might have problems with your
large vessels or medium vessels
and primarily these are the arteries
right because the arteries are the are
the vessels that are seeing those high
pressures and those arteries might be
getting very stiff
or you might have problems with tiny
vessels these are the little arteries
the smallest ones or the arterials and
remember the smallest arteries and
arterials they're not sitting there
naked in your body
they're usually within
an organ right so they're usually within
the kidney
or they could be within the eye so i'll
just draw these two
right so they're usually within some
other organ
and
if you have problems with the smallest
arterials let's say they're breaking
then you really what you're saying is
you're going to have kidney problems or
eye problems so these are the kind of
problems you can get
and because most people are having no
symptoms most people are over here you
really want to catch them before they
cross over from no symptoms to having
symptoms and you want to take care of
the blood pressure problems so they
never develop any symptoms that's the
goal
now unfortunately some people develop
what's called malignant hypertension
and i'm going to write out for you what
malignant hypertension
means it's a few things
and we can actually even draw it on our
figure maybe i'll do that so you have
people with malignant hypertension that
have a rapid rise
in their blood pressure and it causes
damage
and to uh to
the heart
and vessels
and finally
the range that we're talking about at
the rapid rise to
a really high blood pressure sometimes
we think of
these pressures being around 240 over
120 really high blood pressures so on
our graph this could be the person that
you know unlike the person in white this
person maybe had a very quick rise
in pressure
and then it
got very high maybe got up to 120 over
or one 240 over 120 and so this would be
the third point
the rapid rise is the first point and
the fact that they're having symptoms
is point number two so you can see now
how someone with malignant hypertension
could look on this sort of a graph